[Applause]
[Music]
china has starred in what has been the
greatest
economic revolution in the history of
mankind however in spite of this in 2017
both moody's and standard poor's two of
the three main rating agencies
reduced the chinese debt rating
for its part the international monetary
fund itself has been issuing warnings
about this for months yet the chinese
economy is growing strongly but that
does not mean
everything is going well in fact not at
all in recent years
as we've already discussed in a video
that are linked to at the end
china's economy has seen one parameter
soar
exponentially and that's corporate debt
and this isn't small news chinese
corporate debt accounts for almost
170 percent of china's gdp
to give you an idea of what this means
we could say that this 170
gdp level is one of the highest on the
planet
and is for example twice that of the
united states
[Music]
but some of you might be wondering well
if the chinese economy seems to be doing
so
well how did its companies accumulate
such a huge
debt well the truth is that in recent
years chinese companies have gone
on a sort of spending spree all over the
world they've
bought everything foreign companies
ports airports mines
railways even soccer teams
the chinese invasion seemed unstoppable
and that's precisely what caused so many
countries to develop
an aggressive discourse against this
kind of occupation and not only that as
the chinese
have begun investing in the poorest
countries as in africa many analysts
journalists and activists have accused
beijing of
practicing this sort of colonialism
and do beware because this phenomenon is
really quite widespread companies
investors
entrepreneurs government institutions it
does not
matter in recent years the obsession to
get money out of china has been shared
practically
by every person in the chinese economy
now surely some of you might now be
thinking well chinese people buying all
kinds of things from all over the world
people in beijing they've got to be
rubbing their hands together right
well the truth is that no actually
nothing could be
further from the truth in fact
throughout the last year xi jinping's
government has launched
many measures to stop this process i
mean hold on just a moment the beijing
government actually wants to
stop this chinese purchase wave i mean
don't they want to take over the world
well it's not that they don't want to
but they
certainly do have their reasons for this
so listen up
the other face of chinese investment
imagine we want to invest abroad as you
can imagine we can do it in many
different ways for example we can
buy debt from a foreign government from
a foreign company
from a foreign bank we can also buy
shares in another country's stock market
but we can also carry out what is known
as
foreign direct investment that is buy a
local company
open a store a factory a workshop etc
etc
in other words invest in a real asset
in the field
[Music]
well obviously a direct foreign
investment implies a greater degree of
complexity and
certainly greater risk which is why it's
expected to generate
greater profitability of course if it
weren't there would be
no incentive to implement them after all
it's infinitely easier to buy financial
assets while sitting in front of a
computer at the office
or even just in your pajamas at home
well the fact is that paradoxically as
this type of investment has grown in
recent years its profitability has
actually plummeted
according to china's state currency
administration
the rate of return this type of
investment's profitability dropped to
barely 0.4 in 2016.
all despite the fact that almost every
stock market was skyrocketing
therefore in spite of the colonialism
accusations the truth is that many of
the chinese investment projects are
working so
badly that they're more of a headache
than a business of the century
now at this point you might be thinking
well hold up a minute simon i mean
what exactly is the problem here is it
simply that they're just making too
little money
well dear viewer according to what we
learned about corporate debt
yeah it is a large part of this huge
international expansion was financed
with
debt debt that of course must be repaid
with interest and if the investments
fail or don't generate the expected
returns it could create a
huge solvency problem which would
obviously seriously affect
the chinese financial system which
belongs fundamentally to the government
let's take for example the cinehydro and
china railway engineering corporation
case two
engineering and construction companies
owned by the chinese government
you see in 2007 they reached a huge
agreement with the congolese government
in exchange for a concession to exploit
copper
they committed to investing 9 billion in
the african country three billion
in the mine and six billion in
infrastructure two government-owned
companies that had
nothing to do with mining and were
entirely financed by
a chinese government-owned bank
these chinese companies have already
invested more than 2 billion
and so far everything's been a problem
the price of copper fell the reserves
weren't as big as expected the
logistical costs were
really high because they hadn't even
guaranteed their power supply
and of course all of this meant many
costs and many
many delays only nine years later in
2016 were they able to start
extracting copper in much lower
quantities than expected
so whatever the future holds the reality
is that during the last decade this
agreement was a big headache and a great
source of
losses and don't think that this project
was an exception the truth is that in
recent years chinese companies
government-owned and private companies
alike have gotten into
serious debt buying all kinds of assets
without caring about the price
[Music]
but that is not all in addition all
these investments mean capital
leaving the country at such a high rate
that between 2011 and the beginning of
chinese currency reserves plummeted by a
trillion dollars and that my friends is
a lot of
money and it's something that goes in
the opposite direction of what beijing
wants which in recent
years tried to strengthen the yuan so
now we come to the question of why are
chinese investors so eager to get money
out of the country and why do they seem
so surprisingly bad when it comes to
investing abroad well
listen up
the bad incentives
folks the fact that chinese investors
seem so incompetent when it comes to
investing abroad is a matter of
incentives and bureaucracy
see the main priority for the chinese
who manage to make money
is to transfer part of their assets
abroad
so why is this well it's fundamentally a
matter of
legal safety
allow me to explain as you know china is
a dictatorship and that means that if
tomorrow you have a problem with the
political power your money could just
disappear and not only that
as in any dictatorship there are many
restrictions because
if things go wrong what could be better
than having part of your patrony
protected in other countries
it seems pretty sensible right i think
most people
would do it i mean wouldn't you
well that's one of the explanations for
why so many chinese businessmen wanted
to invest their money as quickly as
possible even if it meant
paying a premium a sort of surcharge but
that isn't the only reason
additionally in recent years since 2008
the chinese government promoted easy and
cheap credit as a mechanism to boost the
economy and of course when you can get
into debt under such favorable
conditions you won't be as demanding
when selecting which projects to
invest in yes this is one of the big
problems with expansive monetary
policies they encourage bad investments
that
later are really difficult to pay off
but hold on a moment the entities most
responsible for the huge slab of
corporate debt that we've talked about
have not been private companies but
actually ones owned by the state
[Music]
and this though surprising also has a
lot to do with incentives
see investing outside of the country in
large amounts meant that managers could
puff up their chests before the beijing
government due to the growth that their
companies had achieved
on the other hand it meant many of these
managers could move on to another
country
and charge a lot of money let's say that
their interests are different from those
of their companies
and of course if business was done in
countries as complicated as africa it
was also easier to
take a slice uh get a commission shall
we say in addition
chinese state-owned companies have huge
bureaucratic structures which make
decision making and adapting to any
changes that may occur
very very slow yep state-owned companies
tend to be
much more inefficient well that's what
xi jinping wants to face up to while
trying to consolidate his power
the dangerous game
[Music]
an important point here this huge
shopping maelstrom which is often done
without too much thought
also happened in japan in the 1980s that
is before the great crisis of the early
90s and in beijing they're terrified
that something similar will happen to
them
so what do you think they did well they
introduced a lot of restrictions on
foreign investments in such a way that
now the chinese government can
veto corporate operations abroad for
chinese companies even if they are
carried out
by private companies
and this has a double intention because
in addition to cooling the foreign
investment process it also strongly
reinforces
xi jinping's political power let's say
that with this excuse the chinese
government has taken an
enormous mechanism out of its sleeve to
reward friends
and punish the less loyal
in addition with the excuse of
increasing control beijing is also
promoting the merging of
government-owned companies which
until now worked autonomously to create
huge corporations and this
gives beijing even more power of course
all these actions can weigh on the
growth of chinese companies they can
decrease competition and increase the
bureaucracy and
inefficiency with which the chinese
public sector operates
but yes xi jinping will get even more
power
[Music]
china has many strengths but this is one
of its great weaknesses
even so chinese savings are so high that
it seems difficult to reproduce a
financial crisis like the one that japan
experienced but the risk certainly does
exist
now it's your turn do you think that xi
jinping's ambition will end up
hurting china well leave your answer in
the comments section below as well as in
this survey and i really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos please
also check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast they provided
the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine also this channel is possible
because of our
patreon and the patreons on that
platform please do consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage
and as always i'll see you in the next
video
you